[Music]
hey guys and welcome to a super cult
production of congratulations
[Music]
it's a new episode
it's a new on to the next episode smoke
weed every day um
a little bit of a nate dog a little bit
a little bit of an eight dog beginning
you know what i mean just to spark
things up just to start off on a [ __ ]
nice note smoke weed every day
um
but yeah dude chrisalia.com for tickets
i'm gonna be in dallas i'm gonna be in
uh
wichita kansas
and i'm gonna be in um
uh washington dc and atlanta
crystallia.com those are the [ __ ]
dates that are coming up soon there's
also plenty more go to chrisley.com to
get tickets um and it's still summer
he's wearing a [ __ ] dark shirt it's
still summer but he's wearing a dark
shirt he's doing it because he's worn
only light shirts sit for like the past
however many episodes i've done of
congratulations so he needed to [ __ ]
make it a little bit darker dude he's
not just his happy go lucky guy all the
time he says life rips all the time but
he's not always happy-go-lucky there's
also other parts of him dude
sometimes he puts on a face for the
podcast sometimes he comes and he comes
raw and real and he use right because
you know he's rough uh he's r he's raw
and what you see is what you get with
him sometimes but sometimes he comes and
he does a little tap dancing because
it's going to be a fun episode and
sometimes it's a mix of the two right
but real life is real life and you can't
[ __ ]
you can't shut it out for too long
but my point is is that life rips and
because it's summer dude we got look
what we got
look at the look at the packaging dude
the life look at that [ __ ] dude
wow i love that actually
[Music]
we got the slides dude
boom very cool
very cool for the summer you get in and
out of the pool with that [ __ ] uh i'm a
slide guy turns out i'm a slide guy i
had no idea but you can also get the
bucket hat that we got i don't wear
bucket hats but we got the buck hats got
r a lot of people wrote in where's the
bucket hat so we made bucket hats dude
life rips with that og [ __ ] colorway
with the bucket hats though and there's
a fly in here dude and we can't even
stop it there's a fly in here in this in
the studio the studio is small as [ __ ]
okay and there's a fly in here dude and
the fly's taking up too much space so we
got one of these [ __ ] zap it things
dude i said this is how we're gonna do
because we tried to [ __ ] get the the
fly out of the thing
and uh it wouldn't and we started the
episode and we had to stop it because
the fly was being so annoying so what i
did is i got the zap it do it and i'm
ready now all i got to do is push this
thing in
turn it on push the thing in
okay
yeah got it and then and when the fly
comes i go
and and kristen's really good at it and
i'm so [ __ ] you kind of can't do it
pop actually that's kind of badass if i
did it like that but i don't i always
end up like doing it like that and then
go and then missing and then i catch
myself looking so [ __ ] dude but i got
this [ __ ] for the fly coming i don't
know we'll see maybe because fly's live
for like a day and a half anyway right
so it's like maybe he died already we
don't know but we stopped the podcast
because it was so [ __ ] annoying he
was like landing on the [ __ ] thing
anyway whatever dude chrisleya.com for
tickets go to your go to go go go and
also if you like the podcast take a
minute to just like and subscribe my
babies you know because this is a
[ __ ]
this is a movement all right i mean
we're literally changing the world with
this podcast
um
so yeah and my nose does it work who
knows who knows if my nose works or not
it's been two and a half weeks and they
say by three weeks it should be [ __ ]
gravy and it's not even close to gravy
yet yay
dude it's not all gravy the doctor said
keep it give it three weeks and it'll be
all gravy it's been two half weeks it's
not even close to all gravy yay
dude it's not even close to all gravy
some people say it takes a month some
people think say it takes six months
because there's a lot of capillaries
back there and did calvin bonk my nose
three times this week yeah he did he
bonked it three times this week dude one
was really hard and two wasn't that hard
um but it's fine
still feels like it did before i got the
surgery maybe it didn't work maybe i'm
one of those [ __ ] 20 one out of 20
doesn't work the doctor said which you
know what that means 3 out of 20 doesn't
work right because if a doctor says one
thing it's definitely more because they
want it to make it seem like they're the
[ __ ] artist and they can do it better
than any other doctor but it's really
more than one because i looked online
and sometimes that said up upwards of
five out of 20. it doesn't
work yay dude so we'll see that's one
out of four um but but you know hey look
if we were going to vegas with these
odds we'd come out with a lot of money
so hopefully we'll come out of this
surgery with a lot more air um and i
sleep better whatever
um
yeah man so like and subscribe or
whatever and make love to that [ __ ]
comment section go in there and just
make some love uh
but yeah i really hope this nose thing
pans out when i looked i looked
and uh
it's still very crooked
my septum is still very crooked well now
my septum isn't crooked but the bottom
of my nose is still looks like it's
trying to point a certain way
um and i went in the other day
for my last
uh
what are they not post-op but after the
operation checkup um
a week a week a week after
and then another week after and then now
i have to wait a whole month so
if it's good in a month i'm good he said
the surgery he thinks the surgery worked
though he saw it and he's like oh yeah
it definitely worked he stuck that
[ __ ] thing up there dude so long so
long numbed it up nice
stuck it in there and i said are you
going to clean it out and he said it
looks good and been thinking about that
since it happened because it didn't
really answer my question but it's all
good i don't know if it's clear or not
but uh i say you're gonna clean it up
are you gonna you're gonna clean it out
up there and he said looks good
sir that's so bill dalia how he answered
that [ __ ] question it's unbelievable
so bill bill delia how he answered that
question um
i hate getting my nose numb to do it i
think it's
dude i was talking to my this guy i met
he's a comedian and um uh
uh he's a comedian i don't want to give
too much uh because it's kind of
personal information but he's a comedian
and he was talking about how he was like
oh how did your nose thing go and i told
him and he said yeah i said i'm he said
i'm recovering from a surgery myself and
i said oh what he said he got a
vasectomy i
i can't
a vasectomy i i i can't
i mean
getting surgery in your head and getting
surgery in your
pleasure zone
you know whether that's penis vagina or
anus right and i said the clinical terms
so i can't get age restricted here and
we can't get demonetized because
youtube's throwing that [ __ ] out right
but in your
in under your penis and testicles okay
i'm very medical here in this podcast
because i don't want to get age
restricted right
so behind the testicles
and anus
and or past the penis right
you get a vasectomy what they do they
they basically clip your
wings right okay you know what i'm
talking about you can't get
women pregnant anymore and so he said he
got a a
a vasectomy
and i'm like
why
i i can't wrap
my
head
around someone getting a vasectomy i
cannot wrap my head around it okay
now he's done having kids he's had kids
he's with the same one he's with his
wife you know he doesn't want to have
any more kids and that's pretty final
right
so first of all there's the whole thing
what if you change your mind okay fine
you could just go get another surgery
and get it reversed fine okay
but also dude
just pull
out all right
cause then they're not sticking knives
all in your pleasure zone
huh
cause then you don't have to have
another guy
poking around in your pleasure zone with
something sharp like an exacto blade
really do it
really
just pull out little earlier
and i said this to him and he said well
the
um
the
idea of
not pulling out and having an orgasm
inside my
wife wow sounds worse when you're
clinical with it really to be honest i
mean
splurting sounds way less gross to me
right
um
he says gets me so excited and i go huh
so excited to have eggs to have exacto
blades sticking around all inside your
you're right
really close to your anus and he says
yeah and he said it was three weeks
later and he still feels numb down there
huh
just pull out
dude i do it so early
right when i don't i mean when we don't
want to have kids i do it so
early i do it so early i could like read
a magazine in between when i pull out
and when i oopsy daisy
i mean seriously dude i read a whole
magazine of uh [ __ ] uh cosmopolitan
pull out
read a whole magazine
[ __ ]
l magazine before i oopsie daisy you
know what i'm talking about
i mean jesus dude
i swear to god i'll pull out i'll read a
whole app i'll find out what's wrong all
in the back of highlights before i upsee
daisy dude
i swear to god man
i'll pull out i'll do the new york times
crossword puzzle not even on a sunday
before i oopsie daisy
that's the hard version sunday's easy
one
but i mean god damn dude how are you bad
at pulling out you know why you're bad
at pulling out cause it feels too good
you
chump
back up
back up dude still feels good
what's that i mean bacon's amazing it's
not even like the difference between
bacon and turkey bacon turkey bacon
[ __ ] sucks dude
turkey bacon sucks the only realness
with bacon is the real bacon dude if you
have crispier [ __ ] and by the way dude
you better crisp that up that's like
that's like squirting all up in it
crispy bacon dude
pulling out
early
it's still kind of it's like bacon
that's not that crispy but it's still
banging
it's not even like the turkey bacon
it's not like eating turkey bacon dude
it's not like eating vegan cheese it's
not like it dude
because you're still splurting
i could never get a surgery
i would never get an elective an
elective
surgery i guess no mine was medical i
needed the doctor said my life would be
shorter if i didn't get it so i got it
he said i could die later on he said you
want to be around with your kids way
longer i said yep so i got it but i just
can't imagine getting a vasectomy dude
i'll just pull out man
or stuff some cotton up there or
whatever you know what i mean it's like
[Music]
put a split or where you know condoms
you know what they're not i mean i would
work you know i would do that
i mean surgery dude
crazy
also they don't always work imagine you
got the vasectomy and it didn't work
dude you got the vasectomy and you still
splurted and then you got a kid and the
kid shows up and you're like
well we did we actually no but we do
love you
i i'm sorry yes but yeah
but we love we do we actually love you
so
um
how about r.i.p uh
to pause for v dude my favorite chef
died
my favorite chef died
paul sorvino remember that taxi thing
that he did paul uh youtube um yeah dude
what's up with all these [ __ ]
italian mafia members getting hit
jesus is the number one hitter dude
sorvino
jesus is whacking everybody
here we go
taxi greeting hi this is paul sorvino
actor singer chef new yorker seat belt
user that's right two tickets buckle up
for safety i hope you do wow
actor singer chef new yorker seatbelt
user that's right
for safety and i hope you do too he had
to take a nap after the [ __ ] first
five seconds of it and then and then
they were like we'd actually like to add
to it and he says you get one shot and
did it once and then [ __ ] left
immediately
hi this is paul sorvino actor singer
chef new yorker seat belt user and then
he stares directly at the director says
i'm taking a break and then left
left and this was before cell phones
left and [ __ ] d literally didn't
check his messages for so long
and then his agent called him and his
agent was even part of this deal and
this agent goes like you've got to go
back and you got to finish it and he
went back and said schedule me for two
weeks in advance went back and then did
this part that's right i buckle up for
safety and i hope you do too
[Laughter]
yeah dude this is we mix it up but it
was probably true though man we make
[ __ ] up but it was probably true
r.i.p to paul sorvino man that guy was a
hell of an actor and i happen to know he
had a gold bust of himself in his
[ __ ] condo in l.a but we we we love
him dude we loved him and um
and he was a he's a great actor and he's
my favorite chef and also uh [ __ ] man
that scene where he where he was giving
uh rayleigh to the money in in
goodfellas dude ray leota all right p
ray liotta what the [ __ ] is going on
with all these italians the people are
upset about these minorities losing
their lives and [ __ ] like like trans
issues and all that stuff and and yeah
it's very important but what about
[ __ ] actors who play italian mafia
men
they're all getting hit how many paulies
got whacked by jesus recently
daniel aiello was the one who started it
all remember when danny aiello [ __ ]
died
this was like not even a year ago maybe
a year ago i don't remember time is
irrelevant but it happened danny aiello
ray liotta paul sorvino two guys
probably who play paulie who else
tony sarico he played paulie right dude
uh uh what's his name always ahead of
the curve tony soprano james gandolfini
he ahead of the curve dude
al pacino's next dude we need to make a
[ __ ] parade for these [ __ ]
because their lives are in danger we
need to have a parade on santa monica
boulevard whatever the most italian day
of the year is and you get all these
[ __ ] suit wearers out there on
floats just like
this
sunglasses
[Music]
foreign that [ __ ] song
there i was on the float
little guys play [ __ ] five guys
playing poker on a float
and then another guy with a with a
gun made of flowers just blowing his
brains out that's the float
[Laughter]
and then you try to [ __ ] and as soon
as you arrive at the float when you try
to get on the float hi this is paul
sorvino actor singer chef new yorker
seat belt user that's right i buckle up
for safety and i hope you do too
oh man we love it though [ __ ] npr you
know how he keeps it we keeps it real
like italians um so yeah r.i.p to paul
savino and uh and ray liotta and dana
allo and all the and uh james gandolfini
and all the [ __ ] italian uh guys who
played italian mafia members they died
i guess this was the time man
um
is what it is
so i saw a [ __ ] gray man
the other day gray man
which is uh
you know it's i got to say man
i i want to say this ryan gosling is a
captivating act i mean he is a good
actor that dude is good yes does he
sometimes wait too long to say his line
yes but is that good acting yes
right
take your time be patient if you do
acting classes they say be patient you
know
just because you're mad you don't have
to be patient so ryan gosling takes that
i mean you're probably in a waiting room
with him at this point when he's acting
they'll be like how are you and he's
just like
i'm good and you're just like
you just that was
i had to watch you act for 11 seconds
before you said that
you know but he's good he's captivating
right at least he's watchable he's like
got that denzel thing where you're just
like okay i'm watching him and it's cool
and i see behind his face a little bit
and so the first i don't know 20 minutes
of the movie it's kind of just him doing
[ __ ] and you're just like i could kind
of watch him just kind of walk around i
don't even need to he could be i i don't
[ __ ] it doesn't matter really what's
happening if he's on the screen because
he's just you know what he's doing dude
without even knowing it he's massaging
the lens isn't he
that's what he's doing dude he took the
[ __ ] camera to burke williams that's
what he does right
that's what he does dude he's got a gift
certificate to burke williams and he's
bringing the camera
right he's massaging the lens that's
what he's doing dude and he does that
and like they find out you know he's one
of those movies i'm not going to spoil
it but it's one of those movies where
like the people in the movie are like
numbers you know
[Laughter]
it's like yeah we gotta talk to number
five ah yeah he double crossed us ah
[ __ ] number eight uh number two double
crossed us so that's why he's whacked
and we can't seem to find number three
he went m.i.a in turkey
you're like all right you know and then
you gotta like not only it's hard enough
for me to know whose people who people
are in movies anyway and now i gotta
like keep track of what [ __ ] number
they are yeah number six went [ __ ]
rogue one of them always went rogue
and you're just like all right okay so
five so which one is
and you're like oh wait
ryan
gosling is full
six
okay and he just killed four and then
the five is the okay
and then they're like well we're not
gonna give the job to five are we and
then you find out you're like oh [ __ ]
okay and then you find out that chris
evans is five and he's a [ __ ]
mustache he has a mustache and my whole
thing with chris evans is dude i know
these are the guys that directed captain
america which is [ __ ] great and i
know i guarantee it they were like we
got to give you a mustache we don't want
you to be captain america e and the way
chris evans
acts in this movie dude
since he has a mustache
he might as well twirl it with his
fingers
i mean dude the guy is having a [ __ ]
smorgasbord dude
i mean he is
he has got
[ __ ] courses and he's just eaten the
[ __ ] out of this scenes
and dude you might as well be [ __ ]
is that what we think mr ryan gosling
unbelievable dude
it's unbelievable and then ryan gosling
is in there waiting to act because chris
evans is doing all the twirly mustaches
and shits
and then there's like and and and
anytime ryan gosling or billy uh
bob thornton is not on it
i'm just like dude i'm out dude because
billy bob thornton is one of those other
guys that doesn't need to do much that's
[ __ ] good but dude they got the guy
from bridgerton in it and then this
other chick in it and it's like whenever
they're in the [ __ ] scene i'm like
can we
you know
or the [ __ ] uh
there's another actor in it and it's oh
the anna de armas girl who's who's been
good
uh before you know um i'm a you know
dude they don't want me to get in one of
those [ __ ] movies i swear to god oh i
swear to [ __ ] christ dude if i get in
one of those [ __ ] movies and they
happen to not cut me out of it
bro
johnny [ __ ] steals the scene i swear
i'm going
home with that movie dude you put me in
a [ __ ] part
i'm going you i'll play what i'm going
home with that [ __ ] i show up the first
day i bring a suitcase they say what are
you doing i start putting props in it
they say what are you doing we need
those for the movie i say that's too bad
i'm going home with this one
what do you want me to do you want me to
play british
i'm going home with this [ __ ]
you want me to play japanese
i'm going home with it dude
and i don't even [ __ ] do i'm not and
i don't do it racist either like you
genuinely feel me japanese by the middle
of the movie you're like i actually
forgot kristolya was in it dude did he
get shorter for this part
i swear to god dude maybe i dye my hair
a little bit it gets a little bit black
or even though calvin says my hair is
black it's not as brown
but maybe i'll straighten it you know
not many japanese people out there with
wavy hair let's face it
i don't say much to it and i do that 11
second acting that [ __ ] ryan rent
where ryan golovey does what's his name
ryan gosling does
and i [ __ ] straight up
depends how far back you want to go
into the past
just
packing it up packing up the scene i'll
pack up the scene dude i swear to god
you want to put me in your movie you
will get a [ __ ] bang for your buck
dude
um
yeah but the movie is just like
there's one it's it's so it's just like
you know
i don't know
anytime directors it's like brothers
it's like just one of you guys do it
like what the [ __ ]
so
you know
that's like so
the the thing about a director is you
gotta know your [ __ ]
so well
and you gotta be like nah this is how
we're doing it to have two people do it
it's like okay well then i already like
don't trust it
but there's one there's one scene that's
like the biggest set piece scene like
it's like 20 minutes and it's like ryan
gosling is [ __ ] uh handcuffed to a
park bench and like a million guys are
trying to [ __ ] shoot him and and they
can't for some reason
and
the whole thing is chris evans is trying
to kill him the whole movie but in this
set piece he's behind he's in another
location in
in uh with a bunch of tvs looking at
every monitor and telling everyone to
kill him and and they're trying to kill
him and they can't
and and chris evans is just in the
building like
hakka come on you can't shoot this guy
get him where is he there go get him and
he's like number number 14 get him get
on there he's behind the bench and it's
like
have him be there
have him be there
the whole movie is it's spy versus spy
and one spies tucked away behind some
[ __ ]
tv screens
have him be there
just twirling his mustache
he's got movies on one of the [ __ ] tv
oh great that guy died we got to get
calling back up that's what he's doing
dude you got to have the guy there
anyway dude it's fine the movie's fine i
don't know
ryan gosling's so good
he really is
and i would i would trust me dude i
would tell you if he wasn't
hey
hollywood sup
um
a guy [ __ ] there's too much [ __ ]
on tv man i drove by the other day on
[ __ ] sunset boulevard and it says
shark week
with your master of ceremonies
the rock
you know
like
what how that's the i i i said this
before in this podcast i don't
understand
how much you need to work
like
take
like and i don't look i know nothing
about the rock i'm sure he's a [ __ ]
nice person and a great family man but
it's like
you've got a billion dollars
what you're doing being the master
ceremonies on the discovery channel
what you doing
hey you got a billion dollars you have
billions and billions of dollars
in your bank account you don't use you
don't use billions of dollars
so the rock
you're doing
hey rock what are you doing
being the master of ceremonies
of shark week
there are a few guys who don't have to
worry about [ __ ] diluting their brand
though like him kevin hart kevin hart
he's got like shows it's like
he's like i got pants now i'm selling
pants and you're like uh oh okay does it
is that even successful he's like i'm
gonna be the first billion dollar
comedian you want to buy pants
and you're like i i okay i'll buy these
[ __ ] pants that he's selling i guess
you know
how much could they be paying the rock
for shark week master star he's probably
at home he's probably at this point got
his own studio in his house with a green
screen and he's like oh hammer heads ha
ha oh boy hammerheads are [ __ ] crazy
check this this footage out of this near
death experience you don't want to get
too close to hammerheads or tiger sharks
ah tr
just drinking his [ __ ]
tramana or whatever
his his ozoa or whatever the [ __ ] is uh
uh [ __ ] power drink is oh god huh
do you you see tiger sharks just drunk
as [ __ ] with his shirt off doing dips
drinking his ozo or whatever the [ __ ] it
is
drinking his moana whatever the [ __ ] it
is
drinking his [ __ ] zona iced tea what
the [ __ ] does he make who knows dude you
buy it if you see his face he's always
like this
[ __ ] yeah dude the rock
what how much are they paying him 40
million dollars well i mean what are
they paying them
that's probably too much maybe though
i mean animal planet or discovery
whatever the [ __ ] it's on it's got a lot
of money they got a lot of money
but what do you do be with you be with
your kid no i don't like saying this
because i don't want to tell somebody
how to parent but for the joke man with
your kids
you already fly private you got gold
bouillon coming out janus
right
oh i just took a sh i just took a [ __ ]
oh it's gold still flushes it
aha
gotta drink some more moana where the
[ __ ] what is it ohana
zoa
wow it wasn't so far off man honestly
zoa dude i don't know anything about the
drink but i guarantee he's like from the
feeling of being a hawaiian
i guarantee like in the commercial or
the ad he's always like this is the
essence of when you're feeling hawaiian
and you drink it and ah it tastes like
that true essence of
friendship in hawaii or whatever the
[ __ ] ah zoa
if you want a [ __ ] gold bouillon
from the essence of the family
this is from
tried and true family when you're coming
up in hawaii ah
you know the rock is from [ __ ]
detroit or some [ __ ]
um
i just don't understand it like kevin
hart's doing game shows and [ __ ]
for what
10 million dollars
the name like nine kids never hate on
the [ __ ] man kevin hart is i know
okay you know i know him he's a great
guy i'm just this is jokes
don't know the rock i'm sure he's a
great guy just jokes i actually cause
like you know what i appreciate those
guys i'm making fun but i do appreciate
those guys but it's but still how hard
you need to work dude
that's so crazy to me dude you know what
i you know what i'm doing you know what
i do you know what i'm doing if i ever
make 100 million you know what i'm doing
if i ever make a [ __ ] 100 million
dollars
chilling dude for [ __ ]
dude you won't you won't
see me dude
you won't
[ __ ]
see me man
if i ever make a hundred million dollars
oh dude
i'm walking around in bird box from now
on
dude hey if i make a hundred million
dollars all of a sudden
everyone's daredevil
dude you won't
see me yeah
i swear to god
if the second i make that
500 million i say 50 dude
if i make
50 million dollars dude all of a sudden
we're playing hide and seek for the rest
of our lives where'd crystallia go oh i
don't know check out
bird box
dude you won't this is oh bro
that's it and the only song i'm ever
listening to ever again is [ __ ]
hey
goodbye
hey
goodbye that's it dude just [ __ ]
watching the last samurai on repeat for
the rest of my life i don't give a [ __ ]
man i am done dude
i'm in a boat somewhere i sort of got
naked as [ __ ] only wearing a shirt
that's it just wearing a shirt
just dangling around bleep it to keep it
age restricted i should have said
schlonger hot dog whatever the [ __ ] man
dude just only a shirt only a blazer
actually that's it
so it's still open
a [ __ ] or an oversized shirt it's
just [ __ ] you know hot dog dangling
so it's like like a bell like like a
bell you know like the shirts puffs out
and then like a bell
whatever dude
i swear to god man
i'm done
okay
so
subscribe to my patreon but also don't
too much cause i'm done
when your boy makes 50 milli
a million million million million
i'm a millie a million a million
i love lil wayne dude
when he does that in the beginning of a
lollipop
almost passed out when i did that i ran
out of breath um if you like the channel
subscribe man it really helps man you
know yeah
it's all good
dude i i saw this thing
earlier
hey
pack it up
i saw this earlier so
so it's changed now so everything's
changed right this is the moment people
were worried about everything has
changed okay
now you might be like what chris waiting
with bated breath but i will tell you
but first i'm trying to get this ad off
of my god damn things here we go
this is from ap news
chess playing robot breaks child's
finger at moscow event
just pack it up
got to pack it up
some gauze for my nose dude
this is the beginning of terminator
right so pack it up dude gotta go here
we go
[Music]
you kidding me dude
stop with the robots huh goddammit i
clicked on something i don't want to
continue get it out get it out
ah [ __ ] i opened keynote dude who the
[ __ ] uses keynote on apple
well like we're all steve jobs
to the family
hi family i'd like to talk to you about
something um dude chess playing robot
breaks child's finger of all fingers to
break a child's finger dude
the child is like rook to [ __ ] mouse
5 or whatever and the robot's like
the kid mommy
i am sorry
but you
pissed me off
moscow ap i like how the [ __ ] [ __ ]
always reminds you ap always reminds you
that it's ap
we know a chess playing robot grabbed
the finger of its seven-year-old
opponent and broke it during last week's
huh you know
the robot broke the child's finger
sergey lazarev president of the moscow
chess federation told russian tass
agency of course this is bad oh dude you
know
i mean so russian to have no
the robot broke the child's finger
of course this is bad
if we get new child soon
no that's not the shouldn't we no we get
new child the child has broken finger we
fix by getting new child
a video shared on social media shows the
robot taking one of the boy's pieces and
then grabbing his finger as he attempts
what the [ __ ]
that move is
illegal
mom
now what will you do little
[Music]
seven-year-old crybaby
um
four adults then rush in
struggling to free the boy before
leading him away from the chessboard
lazarev said the chess federation had
rented the robot that appeared in many
previous events
without incident
well
he didn't play with a brat probably he
said the boy was able to play again the
next day and finish the tournament with
his finger in a cast i mean jesus dude
this is insane
what did you just say to me
tommy
me
[ __ ] you crybaby
[Laughter]
that move is legal but it sure
isn't nice
[Music]
crybaby
unbelievable dude
that's it
we gotta pack it up ai this is the
beginning of the matrix
um
how about the fact that this [ __ ]
you know it's like this whole
thing about trans uh with the dave
chappelle thing he's obviously like you
know
one of the best comedians ever
uh he's really [ __ ] a dog with a bone
with this trance stuff which
you know do what you want man and i get
it it's a bigger issue it's about
freedom free speech
but this [ __ ]
dude this is so ridiculous they canceled
a show in minneapolis first avenue is a
theater thing they cancelled
a
show
in minneapolis um hours before it
started
and then they apologized for booking him
dude
this is hilarious in the beginning of
the the in
what's this uh
this is the link bounding into comics i
don't know it seems dave chappelle just
hasn't been able to catch a break
following a recent netflix special last
year i mean honestly dude you know he
made so many tens of millions of dollars
but still like i i hate that shame dude
i hate when people [ __ ] shame people
um but like and you know he's doing fine
i think but like um
they apparently they put out a somebody
signed
there was a petition and 882
people signed it and that was what did
it
120
120
128 i'm dyslexic yes 128. dude that's
not even i thought i mean either way
it's
128 people signed this [ __ ] petition
and they canceled the show
more people were going to beat the show
that's unreal
to let this the fact that 128 people
signed the petition which means if there
was going to even be a protest it would
be way less than that which means
the people in the pro because never
anytime there's like some sort of
protest there's always like the people
that actually care and then there's like
not everybody actually cares some people
go because it's a thing to do you know
like you can't tell me that every white
chick that joined the black lives matter
protest [ __ ] actually gave a [ __ ]
they just wanted to go and take an
instagram picture of it you know what i
mean and that's real [ __ ] period okay
i'm not saying it's not a noble cause
i'm not saying it is risen i have no
[ __ ] idea about black lives matter i
have zero idea i have no idea if that
lady bought a house with the funding six
million dollars i have no idea that's
what the press said but i have no
[ __ ] idea because we don't what trust
suppress we don't know we don't know
[ __ ] about it and i'm not black so i
have no [ __ ] idea i'm barely white
so um
so my point is
people like so they took the show away
they're letting these
fringe people
who who are doing this protesting
dictate
because they think their bags are gonna
get [ __ ] taken i guess
but boy did they fumble the bag dude and
i don't use that kind of slick talk but
boy did they man
they just [ __ ] did another theater
it's like dude it's a whole thing if you
can't beat them join them just let them
[ __ ] play let them talk people acting
like this is like violence towards trans
people what dave chappelle says [ __ ] off
man you know what's violence violence
i'm so it's so annoying oh this makes
people die dude i tweeted something
about [ __ ] this was years ago about
uh pit bulls about how like you never
read any [ __ ] articles about like uh
uh
uh
whatever the [ __ ] dogs are uh havanese
is killing anyone and then i said that
but that's what pit boy pitbull owners
always [ __ ]
going to bat for people saying that
they're the sweetest [ __ ] dogs but
you never see what the [ __ ] tweet was
and like dude whitney cummings called me
crying and [ __ ] like you're leading this
is leading the [ __ ] people uh pit
bulls dying pipples are gonna [ __ ]
die because of this tweet and i'm just
like ow so i she used to be my friend so
i took the [ __ ] tweet down and it's
like
violence is violence dude stop acting
like i'm out there with a [ __ ]
ak-47
about to shoot a goddamn pitbull because
i tweeted about how pitbull's [ __ ]
take legs off of [ __ ] kids
and yeah you know what if havenesses
were bigger they'd probably do it too i
don't [ __ ] know man they were bred
that way i don't even give a [ __ ] dude i
don't even give a [ __ ] man violence is
violence it's so annoying when people
think that because of what dave
chappelle said that some
group of people are now just like in the
fire at the end of a firing squad
anyway dude this episode is definitely
getting [ __ ] age restricted and
demonetized but
whatever the [ __ ] man
it's like it's enough already dude
enough man
wear the dress cut your hair who gives a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] do it
um
i do also think that you know
he's like a dog with a bone on the other
side it's like now he's just trolling
right like now it's like you made your
point and now you're just trolling uh
but it's [ __ ] funny though
you're not gonna convince people it's
not funny dave chappelle is [ __ ]
hilarious and you're not going to
convince people are always going to see
them you know why capitalism they're
going to keep going to see them dude
he's going to keep making people money
and he's going to keep making money and
people aren't going to stop you are
fighting a [ __ ] losing battle
if you want equal rights i get it dude
you know but i i think
you have them or do you i don't know
i guess they're trying to overturn the
[ __ ]
some supreme court justices like
they don't want gay people to marry and
stuff
i don't really know i'm too dumb to know
any of that [ __ ] and i don't read it
i'm just like you you know
let's look at some of this [ __ ]
deserve it scale here oh wait we did the
tinder thing again no no no we got to do
the tinder thing again dude last time it
was so [ __ ] funny
this [ __ ] these tinder people
what has my life come to here we go this
is so these are people on tinder and
this is reddit i guess i'm looking at
yeah right yeah ready and uh tinder uh
these are tinder people talking on
tinder from this [ __ ] what's it called
just tinder okay our tinder uh i'm a
third line mac os engineer so i
basically do very advanced i.t support
for mac based products
and somebody says the person that
they're flirting with says so can you
tell me why my macbook has red
flickering bars whenever i watch
anything on netflix driving mental i
sort of got all my apple products i've
collectively decided to start dying
he says what size macbook do you have he
says i want to say 16 inches but i'm not
sure to be honest he says go to system
settings and select energy savings there
you'll find the checkbook
checkbox automatic graphic switching
which is turned on by default uncheck
the tick box and flickering stops bro
what the [ __ ] is this dude
this is on tinder
this is the least sexy conversation on
tinder i found is this sex talk
hey how big's your macbook
why are they flirting like this worse
flirters dude
i have friends like this
this is just [ __ ] straight up helpful
you're not supposed to be this helpful
on [ __ ] tinder
aren't isn't i guess people find love on
tinder
here we go
rooftop smokes and a pool sash
oh wow what a [ __ ] whoever's types
like that is awful
how about you go jump on the rooftop
how about you go on the rooftop and jump
wow so dick
just to understand clearly this person
this guy writes your response to hanging
out is why don't you kill yourself jesus
huh
people are [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] huh
crazy
and she wouldn't say it to his face too
that's the thing the internet dude
it's like that [ __ ] thing when they
tried to uh
never mind i don't want to talk about
that um here's another one
sean 39
and this is the bio i'm a single father
of three and another one on the way
there in my world if you don't have what
it takes to help me raise my kids then
move aside
and let a real woman step up
must have your own car preferably a
minivan
must be able to cook clean and be
submissive oh lost it at the end there
no taller than five five oh losing it
even must be fit oh keeps losing have
your own source of income and no kids of
your own ah he's a critical tale
lost it in the end there
oh dude that was when like the [ __ ]
uh
red sox lost the series to the mats dude
just went right through his legs or the
d in there
wow i'm a single father of three and an
another one on the way like another one
on the way and on tinder like dude
figure your [ __ ] out man just keep
splurting
while swiping left they're in my world
not your world
no taller than five five and need to be
submissive dude wow this guy hit the
gamut of stuff he's talking about what
he needs talking about how much he loves
his kids and you also gotta be five two
wow women say the same [ __ ] though you
know
women are like
gotta be tall that is crazy dude if a
guy says that it's sexist but if a woman
says that it's just like yeah though you
gotta be over [ __ ] six feet
and then you're like okay i want your
tits to be at least a c and they're like
um perv
here's another one
start a combo with hello gets mad when i
s reciprocate the delicious laziness she
says hello he says hey
she says hello he says howdy she says
hello he says ola
and she says stop saying hi and unmatch
me cause clearly you are too
goddamn lazy and incapable of leading a
conversation
you lazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then he writes hello hahaha
dude
oh [ __ ] yeah dude with the hello that's
one for the [ __ ] boys dude
[Music]
wow girls took it with the [ __ ] mix i
dodged a big cannon and then he [ __ ]
took it back with the [ __ ]
wow man
with the hello wow they're just a one
word hello
let's look at another one here
oh these are [ __ ] hilarious okay here
we go
so in your is it where to ask what's he
living so in your bio you said you are
german do you currently live there or
are you still in the states
someone says german american and at the
moment i'm in germany
my bad
where do you reside where where do you
reside when in the states
she says why are you hyper focusing on
my location
i mean you know
there are seven continents and this is
like part of one of them
i don't care where you live just curious
if our cities are nearby i mean this is
a dating app and i'm not trying to get
into something super long distance if it
goes anywhere i figured it was a pretty
reasonable question dude hyper focusing
and i and then she writes and i travel
between the two and clearly choose
my location
for a reason i do not need to
validate
my location to you
i am going
to trust my gut here oh wow
that died early dude
he says all right ello well kind of
weird this is the tipping point i wasn't
asking for specifics or anything or to
validate anything like i said i don't
really care whether you live
or where you live but i'm looking for
some things
and i like to be upfront about it sorry
i asked hope you find what you're
looking for
i mean thank god for that guy handling
that that way
yeah
wow dad died early
got one more
here um
come on
pretty much how most tinder combos go
anyone under 25 for me wanted a sugar
daddy that's what they said uh what do
you
this just says what starts with what do
you mean otherwise and he says
i and she says i mean money would just
be for my time but i am completely open
to a physical relationship
he says how much he says 300 per meet
he says kind of sounds like paying for
an escort hooker lol she says lol i
don't
i don't know sugar babies have been a
popular super popular thing lately
and he says eating tide pods was popular
for a while too wow dude well you know
what props to her for [ __ ] leading it
with a you know
also with sex involved here do they get
to have sex or is it like just 300 for
hanging the [ __ ] out because it was 300
to meet up for possibility of sex not
worth it although that's what dating is
right for a lot of guys out there
a lot of guys you know how much is
dinner
i mean a hundred
300 is a bit
so a hundred and then three hundred to
four so it's like 400 and then does he
get the [ __ ] doink maybe he gets to
doing maybe not
that's not worth it four hundred dollars
i don't think that's worth it for to
maybe doink if it's a definite doink
then maybe for him let's look at some of
deserve it scales
that we've collected
here we go on drunk people doing things
oh dude so drunk got a platter
on a boat
straight in the [ __ ] wall
wow he actually tried to jump
on a [ __ ] what do you call those
dinghy
he tried to jump on a dinghy dude and
just straight up jumped into the water
like he was trying to go for a dip like
was no hesitation
with the plate the best was that he took
the food for the boat wow what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] deserve it scale seven no doubt
um
okay wcgw parkour on oh already a 10.
dude if you're doing parkour
well unless you die then it's here we go
uh parkour on wet handles and poor
physique condition
i mean you got to be so [ __ ] fit to
do parkour i do it
oh
oh i mean did he think oh god he broke
himself so that's cool dude he flipped
oh
oh of all the pools to do it into that's
the worst pool
dude so slippery so [ __ ] how we grab
let's look at it again dude running up
trying to literally do
try to do a handstand god that guy just
looks like a [ __ ]
like a like a piece of [ __ ] on a couch
you know and he just [ __ ] goes to
grab the handles and do a handstand to
flip over can't get all the way just
gives up in the middle and smashes his
back on the lip of the pool dude that
deserve it scale is eight that's pretty
high dude because of how [ __ ] wow
that was
and how funny it was and how he probably
didn't die and how he didn't get he
didn't get paralyzed so it's okay but
holy [ __ ] you
know god that's funny as [ __ ]
cool how the [ __ ] internet's taking
so long
god people get drunk and they don't give
a [ __ ] i've never backed him if i've
never been drunk
here we go
what is wcgw
oh what could go wrong god i'm so
[ __ ]
sliding down the staircase oh no dude
right i mean this guy's gonna [ __ ]
just fall to his death right
internet's taking a long time we may
have to [ __ ] cut this
here we go
oh no
oh no
the silence dude the fact that nobody
said [ __ ]
dude wait but wait if he was like this
is how people actually die do you know
what i mean like this is crazy like
people die
with by mistakes like this and sounds
aren't made oh [ __ ] that's actually
blowing my mind
that people just die like this it
doesn't make a sound they don't say [ __ ]
and they just instantly die and then
then they're found dude that is
that is blowing my mind right now am i
on coding this is [ __ ] crazy dude
hold on
look
nobody's even saying anything before
he's doing it this is oddly silent
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the way he fell dude he's on the ground
like this
like he is out this dude and the chick
tried to catch him a little bit but she
had her phone in her hand and she fell
down too well i wish this went on longer
man
oh
the least fun party dude
oh god that's if i i i i have
never
seen an airbnb
if that isn't in an airbnb a hundred
percent dude this is unre no one oh it
says no one was harmed dude found an
even quicker way down thinking outside
the box i like it he said that's funny
man
ah don't go too far if you're gonna do
slides down there anything you know also
just don't do those
oh that's good that one is a
nine
you know here's a damaging your
expensive drone for a stunt
oh he's on his drone
so loud
oh no oh no
oh standing on a drone don't stand on a
drone guy
he's got a helmet on for safety and then
throws a ball and
[Music]
you see that coming for so long oh
uh how much is that drone dude
deserve it
that's a that's a 10 that no i'm sorry
that's an eight it wasn't that funny but
oh my god
oh god drones are so annoying huh
there's once a drone in my backyard i
couldn't do anything about it
just sat there for a bit and i looked at
it and i stared
i was acting like i was ryan gosling
just staring waiting to talk
okay here's the last deserved scale
um
this one was supposed to really crossing
the river
what could go wrong crossing the river
oh
here's the what's it like a jeep grand
cherokee just
oh
i wish this was the jeep commercial
oh it's gone dude
what a mess
hey
crawl out
oh my god dude they look it looks like
that that was they were supposed to do
the new jeep grand cherokee
all terrain
take it anywhere
oh god okay well no
hit
back up get out get out get out of the
car the new jeep get out of the [ __ ]
car that's the commercial
dude get out
oh dude i would be crying if this
happened
to me or to my friends or i was there
and saw it happen i would be crying i
would jump in try to help them i'm a
superhero that is uh [ __ ] i gotta say
that's an eight it wasn't that fun funny
but god damn don't do that take the
longer way you know
never going to get there that way um
hey guys that's the end of the episode
on youtube if you want to go catch the
uncut
raw unedited uncensored version go over
to patreon.comcrystalia
where we also drop an extra episode a
month and we also i just did uh um i
just sat down with kristen here and i
did a thing also another one because the
other one went so well uh i did that one
and it's only for patreon anyway it's
only six bucks we also do review mode we
do a bunch of different stuff over on
the patreon so go on over
patreon.comcrystalia and we'll see you
there
[Music]